verás sfa camino desde amará durante más
de siete horas bajo un sol abrasador con
un bebé de nueve meses en su vientre en
su vida de la violencia en etiopía dejó
atrás a su marido detenido por las
fuerzas de seguridad y a su hijo de
siete años con las ropas todavía
ensangrentadas recuerda el momento del
precario parto
[Música]
hernán cuando estaba dando a luz en el
desierto con un fuerte solo es ingente
sin ropa después de algunas personas
vinieron a verme y le dieron al bebé un
baño en un charco llevo aquí 14 días y
no he recibido nada no tengo ropa que
ponerme al barajar tanto en baraja y
hernán jara sea que les mande muy 4 su
historia se repite entre los más de 40
mil etíopes que han escapado de los
enfrentamientos en la región norteña de
tigre con el sonido de los disparos de
fondo esta joven de 25 años dio a luz en
el camino ahora sobrevive junto a su
hija recién nacida en el campamento de
una cuba en sudán casa la mata toser ha
alejado de alexander la no tengo leche
para ella y ahora toda la noche y no
tengo ropa en realidad no tengo nada
eres
yo solo tengo este vestido y ni siquiera
tengo ropa interior
según naciones unidas al menos
setecientas mujeres embarazadas han
cruzado la frontera entre etiopía y
sudán superando una dura travesía con
las dificultades añadidas del embarazo y
sin medios para mantener a los futuros
niños con el valor del juego estuve
caminando durante cuatro días por el
campo caminaba me detenía y descansaba
no había comida ni agua trataba de
pellizcar cualquier cosa por el camino
hacía calor no tenía nada dormía en esta
bufanda me despertaba y caminaba de
nuevo el campo sudanés de un frac uva
que volvió a reabrir albergó una vez a
refugiados que huyeron de la hambruna en
etiopía en los años 80 pero ahora el
país está abrumado por sus propios
problemas económicos y la pobreza
extrema mientras se prepara para recibir
a sus vecinos cuando el conflicto etíope
se recrudece